oggi mi sento fortunata con
l'opportunità di salutarvi di
presentarmi e darvi una certezza dirvi
che cosa sono
ebbene sono un essere umano si è una
cosa ovvia lo sapete già che sono un
essere umano ma perché lo sapete perché
mi avete visto appena sono apparsa su
questo palco perché ora sono qui davanti
a voi in tutta la mia umanità
sì perché pensandoci bene è un po una
fortuna no di questi tempi conoscere
qualcuno
incontrandolo di persona addirittura si
può diventare amici sulla piattaforma
digitale no conoscere cioè intraprendere
qualcosa di più che va al di là del
vedere cercare qualcosa di più profondo
ma il mondo oggi come fa a cercarmi come
fa a distinguervi fra tanti a conoscermi
forse con questa immagine posso
rispondere alla mia domanda o forse no
beh questa sono io perlomeno questa
informazione al mondo
più che sufficiente qui c'è tutto quello
che la società contemporanea sente il
bisogno oggi di sapere di me e per
essere più veloci più efficaci per far
funzionare meglio le cose ma vi faccio
una domanda a voi qui in questa sala a
voi umani
basta che tipo di persona posso essere
io che idea vi siete fatti di ma
guardando questa immagine posso essere
riassunta efficacemente attraverso una
sequenza di lettere e numeri oppure se
vi faccio vedere queste immagini invece
che cosa vi succede
beh secondo me è successo qualcosa di
più dentro di voi perché gli occhi il
sorriso l'espressione il volto sono la
rappresentazione così forte della mia
umanità di avervi istintivamente
provocato secondo me un'emozione
l'emozione che empatia e che quindi vi
ha creato questa cosa straordinaria
perché ricordiamoci il nostro viso
comunica e la comunicazione è una delle
più grande con queste umane
io per esempio per come sono fatta io
specialmente io sento sempre bisogno di
comunicare qualcosa di me al mondo
circostante e lo faccio in tutti i modi
possibili
ad esempio oltre alla mia parola alla
mia faccia sono anche capace di produrre
questo e questo cos'è beh questo è una
sofisticatissima sequenza di movimenti
del mio corpo del mio braccio della mia
mano guidati dalla mia mente dal mio
cervello dai miei occhi
tutte queste cose insieme producono
un'azione scontata ma altamente
qualificata
è un messaggio molto personale che si
traduce poi in un gesto e questo non è
un gesto qualsiasi è qualcosa che si può
leggere e questo è straordinario e
straordinario che l'uomo abbia inventato
un insieme di segni che possano
diventare lettere insieme di lettere che
possono diventare parole un insieme di
parole che possono diventare pensiero e
paradossalmente sorprendentemente alta e
sofisticata tecnologia la nostra
scrittura
forse noi non ci rendiamo più conto che
siamo capaci di creare questa
eccezionale tipo di traccia un messaggio
che è la rappresentazione di noi stessi
che non può essere copiato non può
essere previsto ma soprattutto registra
lo stato d'animo che noi stiamo provando
nel momento in cui lo stiamo tracciando
che cosa più mi piace di questa traccia
beh sicuramente in un mondo così
digitale la sua unicità così rara la sua
forza la sua energia la sua personalità
la mia in questo caso ho scritto io
la sua bellezza e la sua dinamicità la
sua capacità straordinaria di
trasformare il flusso di miei pensieri
in scrittura
la sua sincerità io non posso far a meno
della mia traccia perché tramite essa
esprime meglio le mie idee
ricordo meglio le cose e alleno la mia
mano a essere più precisa e quindi a
creare cose sempre più belle e a questo
punto mi sembra un po di sentire i
vostri pensieri
sì va bene abbiamo capito però lei farà
sicuramente un lavoro molto più
sensibile a queste cose è molto più
allenata di noi si in parte avete
ragione io lavoro in un settore
sensibile a queste tematiche o perlomeno
lo era che pretende la conoscenza la
competenza su queste tematiche per lo
meno lo faceva faccio parte del mondo
della comunicazione del graphic design
del lettering e soprattutto della
calligrafia e avete sentito bene
calligrafia cioè bella grafia una cosa
superata antica siete certi ho scelto
molto tempo fa di fare questo lavoro e
mi rendo conto che moltissima gente non
si rende conto e non lo sa però senza
l'addestramento che questa particolare
disciplina da nella percezione degli
spazi dei bianchi dei neri dei vuoti dei
pieni nella composizione e molto altro e
questo lavoro non funziona tanto bene
tutti i graphic designer italdesign
dovrebbero conoscere questa particolare
disciplina e scusate se proprio proprio
come un buon medico la conoscenza
dell'anatomia della lettera e si dice
proprio così
anatomia della lettera in tipografia
senza quindi la conoscenza della sua
anamnesi della sua struttura della sua
storia
il creativo non è in grado di trovare di
fare poi la diagnosi e quindi di creare
di trovare poi la soluzione al messaggio
creativo permette
al grafico al creativo di modernizzare
l'antico e quindi di adattarsi al
presente e inventare delle nuove
anatomie credibili lettere contemporanea
lettere vive che possono poi
tranquillamente far parte del mondo
digitale perché anche i compiuti unite i
caratteri che voi utilizzate all'interno
con il vostro computer tutti i giorni
beh qualcuno ce li ha messi dentro non
sono nati con la macchina e cile messi
dentro un umano un tile designer dalla
precisione con la sua conoscenza la sua
sensibilità e poi la sua traccia e poi
insieme alla macchina l'esecutivo c'è la
trasformazione della sua del suo lavoro
in digitale e spesso io rifletto queste
tematiche
sinceramente combatto un po sono sincera
la tendenza a pensare che la tecnologia
ci sostituirà in tutte le nostre
esperienze di vita e che questo sarà un
po diciamo il nostro futuro
beh io sono d'accordo invece sono molto
fermamente convinta che il lavoro
d'equipe è la strada migliore
io lavoro prima con la mente poi con le
mie mani e poi alla fine con la macchina
perché credo che l'azione umana alla
base delle cose cioè nella diciamo la
progettazione di ricerca e di progetto
sia veramente essenziale per raggiungere
risultati di alta qualità dovete pensare
che lo studio della storia della
calligrafia delle degli stili storici di
scrittura permettono al creativo per
esempio di inventare il marchio in senso
credibile c'è che un progetto credibile
efficace e marchio di un'azienda la
testata di una giornale la copertina di
un libro e tantissimi altri elementi
atti al messaggio comunicativo e la
calligrafia oltretutto oggi anche se
difficile pensarlo è la mia attività più
viva in tutte le sue espressioni come
per esempio insegno il corsivo al ai
corsi di formazione per gli insegnanti
della primaria tengono laboratori di
calligrafia nelle scuole con gli
studenti veramente di ogni età e di ogni
livello
insegno lettering ai graphic design
certamente la scrittura storica con
pennelli ski inchiostro certamente però
anche i tatuatori se vogliamo una
professione particolare è interessato al
suo tipo disciplina e si avvicina per
migliorare il proprio lavoro el
insospettabili insospettabile attualità
della calligrafia e qui vorrei
soffermarmi un attimo apriamo una
parentesi al mondo della scuola è un
campo d'azione cui tengo molto perché in
un mondo così digitale e in un momento
in cui la scrittura a mano
diciamo è considerata cosa un po
scontata non mi sembra non tanto
prioritaria nella didattica e venne a
ricordare della mia esperienza che la
calligrafia fatta bene nelle scuole ha
delle ricadute incredibili su tantissime
altre competenze che sono comunque
richieste agli studenti la memoria
l'apprendimento efficace e veloce
l'ordine la produzione scritta e orale
adeguata la precisione del segno la cura
del dettaglio ha anche un effetto
calmante la calligrafia fatta bene a
scuola a scuola mi chiedono aiuto
imparare a scrivere bene proprio perché
si è capito che alla base di tantissime
cose la bici della cultura
dell'apprendimento
dalla mia esperienza diretta so che la
calligrafia e tutti i suoi aspetti
manuali e hanno un successo strepitoso a
scuola e soprattutto tra gli adolescenti
che stanno crescendo stanno lavorando
alla loro crescita e sono alla ricerca
della loro identità la sorpresa di come
bello scrivere a mano un messaggio
è veramente insospettabile il mio
momento in cui loro al riparo del copia
incolla riescono a trasformare la loro
traccia personale in un messaggio
leggibile e dedicato è un'esperienza che
li fa innamorare e vogliono ripeterla
vogliono ripeterla e non se la
dimenticheranno
siamo però consapevoli che la tecnologia
comunque entra in ogni momento della
nostra vita ormai fa parte della nostra
vita
in un certo senso ci sta secondo me
comunicando un po che della nostra
umanità non abbiamo più tanto bisogno
diventa sta diventando un po un limite
non un peso
ma la macchina coi suoi efficientissimi
tempi i suoi tempi e ci impone dei ritmi
che forse sono difficili da cucire su di
noi perché noi siamo umani
la macchina cos'è la macchina e futuro
innovazione ripetitività quantità
clonazione omologazione sintesi fretta
calcolo velocità efficienza l'umanità
l'umanità e futuro innovazione unicità
qualità originalità creatività lentezza
narrazione cultura intelligenza fantasia
sorpresa invenzione scoperta idea genio
e poi siamo tempo il ritmo del tempo
pulsa dentro di noi la nostra scrittura
a mano e con un respiro un battito che
ci ricorda semplicemente che stiamo
vivendo la nostra scrittura è una danza
fatta con tutto il corpo che può essere
tracciate nell'aria è una sorta di
meditazione fatta di silenzio ea noi
umani di silenzio fa molto bene che
bello scrivere per esempio un messaggio
a una persona con noi vogliamo bene
dedicarli oggi le due cose più preziose
che abbiamo il tempo e il nostro segno
che è la espressione autentica di noi le
nostre lettere escono fuori dal nostro
strumento può essere la biro la penna
stilografica la matita il pennarello non
ha importanza quelle lettere ce
l'abbiamo messa solo noi dentro perché
solo noi le facciamo così sono noi
scriviamo in quel modo è più le facciamo
e più diventano belle è l'applicazione
di alcune regole la bellezza come
conseguenza dell'applicazione delle
regole e di un ritmo regolare ma sono
consapevole non posso più fare a meno
del mio telefono per mettermi in
contatto
non posso più fare a meno del mio
computer per fare gli esecutivi per la
stampa e quindi a soddisfare mio cliente
non posso più fare a meno dello scanner
che però è un mio migliore amico
costituisce il tramite tra la mia mano e
la piattaforma digitale il mio scanner
che mi permette di conservare
perfettamente intatto integro il mio
segno personale e trasportarlo
all'interno del mio progetto digitale il
mio scanner che mi permette di
conservare tutta l'esperienza tutta la
manualità più accumulato maturato in
tutti questi anni e che computer da solo
non potrà mai creare da solo non potrà
mai ricrearlo allora è naturale
evoluzione
secondo me la coesistenza cuore
algoritmo mente macchina bellezza
automazione la nostra testa
e i bit che pulsano dentro di noi si
uniscono ai big tecnologici creando una
forza l'uno non esclude ne sostituisce
l'altro la nostra personalità la nostra
manualità è intatta crea bellezza non
entra in conflitto con la tecnologia
perché se usata bene ci completa e varia
a riempire i vuoti delle nostre
imperfezioni
sì perché noi siamo imperfetti ma unici
e geniali e straordinariamente umani e
come dice einstein i computer sono
incredibilmente veloci accurati e
stupidi gli uomini sono incredibilmente
lenti inaccurati intelligenti
l'insieme dei due costituisce una forza
incalcolabile e mi piacerebbe terminare
questo mio questa mia riflessione
riportando un attimo il pensiero un
testo che mi ha colpito molto
scritto da mario perniola lui diceva che
quello che ci manca oggi non sono certo
nelle notizie nei dati nelle
informazioni però siamo subissati da
notizie dati e in forma
e in qualche modo non riusciamo ad
appropriarsene
non riusciamo a fare le nostre perché
questi dati queste informazioni
diventino autentica comunicazione
bisogna che qualcuno si assuma l'onore e
l'onere di farne una sorta di traduzione
leggendaria di trasformare in storie
quelle che sono soltanto dati e beh io
qui ci vedo moltissimo della mia
esperienza soprattutto quando lavoro con
i ragazzi è questa magia di trasformare
il dato in parola scrittura e storia ci
dà la chiave della propria appropriarci
dell'informazione per farla nostra
per memorizzarla e senza la scrittura a
mano che è una traduzione visiva grafica
multisensoriale eccezionale potente si
imprime poco nella nostra memoria di
umani
e a proposito di memoria chi di voi oggi
si ricorda i numeri di telefono dei
propri familiari e gli amici più cari
credo pochini forse nessuno e se il
telefono smette di funzionare
forse noi in questo caso ci siamo
affidati troppo alla sua di memoria
forse la memoria una delle competenze
che faremo bene a conservare nel tempo
forse sarebbe anche bello andare a
cercare quali altresì sono assopite e
risvegliarle o forse semplicemente vi ho
fatto venire voglia di ritrovare la
vostra di traccia anche col telefono in
tasca perché noi siamo umani
vogliamo molto di più ea noi umani una
sequenza di lettere ed i numeri non ci
basta per amare grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]